what's up reject nation greg and john
here today we are going to watch episode
4 of star wars visions been enjoying
this show quite a bit so far guys i want
to say thank you to everyone who's been
watching with us
to this point means a lot to have you on
board if you haven't yet jumped on board
the reject nation cast your vote sign
your citizenship your nationality
allegiance to the region is taking too
long
hit that like button if you enjoyed this
video subscribe and click that
notification bell too to get notified
when our next reaction for visions is up
we are unloading these throughout the
week full length watch alongs where you
sync up with the timecode over at our
patreon page you cover a whole bunch of
shows over there as well at the same
tier for reaction highlights and watch
alongs included lastly pratham jindal
thanks for editing this down for us bud
you rock
[Music]
you can i must be cautious wherever i go
have you finished exploring the planet
yet not yet but i did find something i'd
like to show you it doesn't suit you
that mask
oh you comfortable back there i'd rather
walk but it's not too bad we can't have
a bride with dirty feet where we're
going is far too sacred for that
i wish my parents could be here to see
this
i have no doubt they'll both be watching
they're one with the planet now yes
along with your parents
that bride should be walking herself
this is beautiful music i know
and all i can feel is this guy's back
pain
his aching feet
i'm probably bleeding any minute now
she steps in a pile of
[ __ ] damn it
[Laughter]
don't look at me
we are the sky we are the forest we are
the river we are the forest we are the
river we are one
we are wiccans
i am one with the force the forces with
me
[Music]
just like this
we're making a path for the fish
[Music]
[Music]
oh no
traumatic memories
no jesus
they attacked by the empire
the people of this world have a deep
respect for nature their rituals allow
them to live in harmony with is that
what you wanted to show me
only because an old friend of ours had
roots on this planet
my master
did he know they would be going up there
to be doing that he's been following
them around for a week
the separatists stripped them all of
their resources yes and all just for war
that's all that war is nothing but loss
together
[Music]
hey we've got the wipe
[Music]
i love how this feels like a real anime
with stuff that's uh has a star wars
aesthetic inspired travelers youtube
drink with us ah thank you blue
yeah i think it was blue yeah get that
blue
take the mask off
it's fine they're all vaccinated
[Laughter]
we're all in each other's bubble we
don't go anywhere the separatists left
their battle droids behind
but the raiders found them and
reprogrammed them all
they formed an arm
they wanted the village chief as
collateral
but his granddaughter volunteered to
take his place and they're coming to
take her in the morning
oh jesus this drink isn't strong enough
imagine
being imprisoned by invaders to save
your ground
are you really okay with this sister
some of us are ready to fight
you may have given up hope sister but
not all of us have not the six of us
i've already made my decision sister
please understand what kind of wedding
is full of mourning
no these are all very good-looking
villagers
[Laughter]
oh he doesn't want her to go either i
know what you're trying to do it's not
as if i care about that little code of
yours why should i pretend to if you
know what he's trying to get you to do
i feel like you're kind of leaning
towards maybe wanting to do that thing
he's trying to get you to do
can you feel the majina as well can you
feel
i'm sure you understand i have a bad
feeling about this
you think
i'm being reckless what do you think
would happen if i go i'll be able to
protect them all i won't be alone
oh
you coming with
they're gonna kill you man
[Music]
[Music]
we're in this together
[Music]
can they consummate the marriage got to
right then and there
make a little forced baby
[Music]
are you the village chief's replacement
yes
i'm coming with you in his dead i like
this planet
i'll serve as collateral to avoid any
unnecessary conflict you'll forgive me
if i appear to be overly cautious
oh no
no one will try to resist you anymore no
exceptions i'm afraid
[Music]
oh
yeah
where's it yep
love when they do that
frozen blast
oh you can't change the river's flow by
casting a stone live in harmony with
nature and you'll change together
may you rise
and may the force be with you hmm
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it is awesome
[Music]
i love the battle droid voices
the empire wow great landing
oh [ __ ] nice
what are you
some kind of a monster
i am a jedi
oh [ __ ] lightsaber
yellow blade
[Music]
oh
[Music]
cool
[Music]
[Music]
oh
punch it
that was great i love that it's great
mood oh buddy yeah let's talk about that
but before we do
that wasn't
george takai was it
semi sounded like him i just think it'd
be cool if george takai was in a
if he was a traitor betrayed star
fleet
found himself in a star war no there's
no george takai no
matter of fact i don't recognize any of
these people
[Laughter]
no maybe karen fukuhara but
no that's kara fukunagawa the director
yeah that's right
almost it
is
i could see this being an episode that
maybe not everyone really enjoys a lot
this is like you got different
animators involved different just people
directing this like they're all there
really is this is true anthology of what
they're doing here
um
and i don't know like i don't know how
people feel about this obviously
but
personally all i could do is talk about
my personal take on it i loved the
i guess the world comes to mind is the
meditative qualities that this episode
in particular has
because it it we see
i could see this being something that
people don't like because of this
and i could see some people liking it
because of this what i'm about to say
and i tried saying it really quick
during the reaction is that
in a lot of ways this felt like
uh like some slice of live anime
that had a star wars aesthetic to it
versus like the other three that we
watched which feel like
star wars with an anime spin to it yeah
it's like a star wars adventure through
an anime scope yeah
and uh i i thought that i'd love the
build
to what's happening here becomes a
little bit predictable once you realize
okay she's definitely a jedi yeah
whoever she is
um
i think she's called f in the credits
but yeah once you realize she is a jedi
like okay it's gonna be that classic
star wars story of saving the village
and uh i i found myself like
really swept up in the moment where she
does show up like as obvious as a moment
it's gonna be when the blaster goes off
i thought that because of its pacing
because of the tone that it struck with
letting you feel the nature vibes but
then also it's it's like beautiful
serene music
i felt encapsulated by the moment when
she does show up and stops the laser
beam
and or laser blast
stops the laser blast
and then uh it's like that that that
tracking shot they do of her and just
the mood it or the orbit of it all was
so beautiful and that i found myself
like
just swelled by the moment of it and so
yeah i thought it was like really cool i
thought it was like badass you know i
like how you don't know
the jedi and the allies real names i
don't like you don't know who they are
so this is obviously after order 66
and uh jedi are you know or the the few
remaining ones or that are alive or on
the run or hiding their identities
so
getting just another aspect of this that
doesn't tamper with the you know uh the
chronological timeline or the canon of
star wars
still allows us to feel like if disney
ever wanted to just be like yeah make
that canon it could work absolutely
absolutely like it's not the nice thing
about it being removed from so many
things is that there's a lot of space
for it to exist yeah yeah because it's
not uh infecting any like major nexus
points you know fixed points in the lore
but yeah i really enjoyed the aura and
the tone of this overall i like
that after especially the first three
episodes this is something that has you
know a lot of very classic star wars uh
tenets and and you know again yeah
saving the village stepping up as you
know the reluctant uh you know
apprentice and you know the sort of sage
wisdom of the uh you know the teacher
and whatnot uh but yeah i really
appreciated the just direction of this
whole thing because you know it had like
you said a very meditative tone that
made it very engrossing it's like it's
not a super fast moving episode and it's
also one that doesn't have
a ton of expository dialogues so while
there is definitely some you know i felt
like they only use dialogue as much as
they really needed to and like even the
vocal performances are very uh sort of
lilting or they're not like frantic you
know it's like they take their time
everything about this feels like it
takes its time and and that's something
that i feel like is is to me part of the
magic of star wars is when it does pull
back into the beauty of just this world
and
even
you know seeing what different cultures
across it reminds me of you know talking
to the the producers the interview and
they name check this episode as being
sort of an example of let's go explore
other cultures in this universe and
while it does yeah come back around to
some very classic star wars actions and
star wars ideas
it still felt yeah like we are just kind
of living for a moment in this other
pocket of the universe before this young
jedi decides to strike out on a new
adventure and so yeah i loved both
cutting back and forth between her and
her master you know watching them as
they do their thing and then seeing how
it will ultimately relate to what's
going on with the bride and her and her
you know suitor there you know the guy
who's always with her
yeah you only really get to know the
village people
you know the
the hot sisters that's right and her
five friends willing to fight
the resistance
sick one was called saka and then i was
like ah man
osaka
avatar the last urban oh boy
a little brain fried at the moment
people excuse this extremely slow rhythm
of an episode um yeah i appreciate it
actually i could have really gone for a
slow moment
to have a slow episode i'm like this is
perfect for the way my brain is operated
today i can totally just let myself get
lost in here some beautiful music i
thought like with the flashbacks too i
like the handling of it because
everything just seemed to be a tone poem
with this episode
you know what i really appreciated is
the battle droids even even as goofy as
they are here at times in the episode
they had this one shot where they were
like marching through the flames and it
just felt so hellish and i
it was the first time i was like that is
the most imposing or domineering
moment i've ever seen of the battle
droids
especially in animated form i always
find them just so goofy and
non-threatening and then to get them in
that little image i'm like oh damn
there's something that feels very
uh very menacing about them walking
through the the brimstone at that moment
so and it provides like a heck of a
contrast to everything else in the
episode and i thought with like
looking at another culture
that was all about being in tune with
nature was really cool because
you know it's almost
hippie like except everything is
obviously physical and real and not just
you know this not an insulting hippie
like when i say that you know i'm a
spiritual guy myself to a certain extent
to certain areas of my life so
yeah i love how like because star wars
in so many ways like a lot of the
beliefs of the philosophical beliefs of
the jedi and the mindset
are often you know like um spiritual
practices that people have in real life
and the cool thing about star wars is
that they
they manifested into like physical
demonstrations of things you know like
the force and all that it being one
thing you know it's like you some people
can call a force being something that is
like what law of attraction is in a lot
of ways right
and uh what i would say with um
this is it's a similar thing of just
really being in tune with nature
you know and the talk of like
environmentalism is much more palpable
than ever almost at palpatine it's a lot
more palpable than ever so having this
like physical connection with nature
where you really do see that the human
beings who do tune themselves into it
have this relationship with nature and
nature does
vocalize itself
uh i i thought like having like the past
show itself like that seeing the
memories was was a cool thing to add
into the star wars lore
the memory of the planet yeah yeah yeah
it's great
because uh the planet does feel
yeah it's a living thing
and that's my point is like you really
get the planet as a character here
and uh that's not something you can
often say with star wars a planet so you
can say that like aesthetically yeah
but you know to really feel like for for
a world
for a universe where you're constantly
going to a bunch of worlds that i don't
remember more than 99 of the names of
it's cool to have a planet that feels
like a real character with thoughts and
emotions yeah that feels tangible and
like you actually just spent a little
time there yeah you know like i feel
like we just took me a few minutes to
make a good point it's okay
and anyone who made it this far in the
video will be will be rewarded
will be rewarded for their faith
sticking by
but yeah yeah it's i mean this is a
highlight yeah this might be
my second favorite
so far maybe we'll see we'll see as we
go
if the audience only watched the first
four episodes i would say that their
order
is
one
three
four two okay
no no let's be more dickish okay i would
say it's three
one four two okay
um
i
i personally have an order of
one
four three two three two yeah yeah i
think so yeah that's my order right
there
yeah
order 66 guys what'd you think about
this episode i don't want to i would
love to walk away from this and be like
oh hell yeah most people like this great
i would love that i would love that i'm
not i'm not in the business of trying to
be right and when i am wrong i just go
what are you gonna do
it's a good healthy philosophy right
there hey we're all wrong sometimes
so guys subscribe
click that bell hit that like button and
hey i think we got room for a patron of
the day shout out
daniel gallacher daniel's son
daniel you are like my karate kid
you are also
a man who would
drink my milkshake mm-hmm
you know daniel
you're also uh
uh you had you had me at hello daniel
you you uh
why'd you go with that one because it's
a notable movie quote i didn't know if
you were going after a theme beyond
movie quotes i was going after daniels
oh daniel okay daniel
and daniel plane
i get that okay okay give me another one
let me go again all right um
just skype it off with one more
uh the dan band
who's it was another daniel you're
thinking too much maybe you think it
just bans danny's
oh hey gotta walk before you can crawl
reverse that danny ocean
oh damn and rusty greg way way to go
yeah
all right daniel calico that's your
shout out today
well thank
let's quote gallagher's next time
[Music]